you know this show is brought to you by
the cash shop I am determined to make
this number one finance app add more
entertaining this time I want to do that
I just feel like we're we we need to
make these more like let's sing a song
well almost heaven John and Blue Ridge
cast a shadow River laughs is a cash
half there can't chef bend the trees
younger then the cash out - out like a
breeze - a bros cash at home - the cash
a ba bo cash am joonyoung take me home
in cash afro that good I'm not sure we
might have just lost that sponsorship my
guy in Spain sign up for the
cash-strapped use promo code Whitney not
only we instantly received $10 but cash
up will also donate $10 to The Trevor
Project an amazing organization that
provides Protective Services to lgbtqia+
youth across America
don't forget promo code Whitney when you
download cash from the a store
I just wear the headphones because I'm
so low it might look nice with your hair
it just it never looks cool with my hair
I never I always look it never like
improves the look but sometimes I feel
like I can't ease it up why do you wear
the headphones just make it look like
you're important basically it makes me
look like I have some authority around
her or something I like people want to
hear me make sure my voice is right it
makes me feel like I know what I'm doing
yeah but I don't like it your official
start that's right like it makes me just
feel like we're making a show yeah I'm
things are on right cuz I can hear
myself but I also feel like I yell and
this makes I this magnifies how loud I
am so that makes me talk a little less
that's so weird I think if you wore
headphones you talk louder really yeah
have you ever noticed when people um
talking to their phones they talk louder
and you're like it's not a Oh like hey
when you're like why are you yelling
into the yeah there's some sort of thing
where you think you have to yell I don't
know what it is it's like a weird like
audio dyslexia or something but I'm too
loud and I'm trying to talk softer and
be sexual well and attractive to man
well I have their child so I'm always
yelling cuz I just think no one hears me
I know oh there's no one's listening I
was not hurt as a child but yeah exactly
what I tell people
and I also repeat myself a lot oh yeah
because when I was a kid I had to say
something four times in order to get
heard and but it also makes me feel
really uncomfortable when like the table
goes silent people are actually hearing
me I'm like no this is not how life is
supposed to work well not unused to
being completely ignored and disregarded
oh we're ready yeah okay Kate Upton is
what we started right I never know when
we started do you remember how we met I
actually and I actually don't know I'm
sure it was really really great
wait was it did did Ben Bruno introduce
us no okay
nope keep trying keep guessing
I don't remember we met first of all I
think people will probably be surprised
to know that we're real friends I don't
think people know we're friends uh yeah
we're friends right we're real friends
we met at the Vanity Fair party with
Leslie yes I feel like we knew each
other before that but no that was our
meeting I think when we met we were like
oh we know each other yeah that makes
sense cuz I was drinking - yeah that I
don't really fully remember meeting you
definitely were drinking yeah I saw I
don't expect you to remember that but we
met at the Vanity Fair party and I
remember I was so out of it because that
party for people that don't know it's
like the biggest party basically of the
year yeah in Hollywood and it is a
shitshow night a nightmare you can
barely walk through anywhere and
everyone is like an icon yeah and so no
shoving there's no like that's De Niro
that's already Caprio like I expose
behavior in like nine pairs of Spanx
like can't breathe he had to fart so bad
and well no one would no one who knows
you already because it's so tight if
you're like dalinar together grip of
vegan fucker and I was spinning out
because that red carpet is it's like a
hundred yards long and there's what like
a thousand photographers yeah it is so
crazy and I always have anhedonia like
right as I'm going down and I because I
always bomb the red carpet I'm never
good at it I don't know what to do with
my hands well it's also that red carpet
because most actors are short but all
those photographers shoot from a bad
angle for tall people so we're really
screwed so maybe it's not you bombing
maybe it's the photographer glowing my
mind because I'm like why are all my red
carpet photos all nostril yeah so any
literally they're coming up at you cuz
they're trying to make the actors and
actresses look taller but we're already
tall so they just like crop us at the
head
even think of that cuz they're on like
scaffolding they're on lynches and
they're designed for all the actors that
are like 5 - exactly trying to make them
look statuesque but actual people that
are tall just look like I have six chins
exactly that's why you just got to keep
your head real low how do you know what
to do you you do like on the red carpet
you know what to do with your hips you
know what to do your hands so weird like
it's a lot of people taking my picture
no but like I remember the first time I
went to Vanity Fair I like freaked out I
was like why do I look so terrible or
looks like one photo that's good and
then I figure it out it's the difference
between Hollywood or like any fashion
party they're shooting you better
because they're used to all the tall
model that's so interesting and I always
panic because you know what I have a
flashback to school photo day remember
would you have to like wait in line to
take one photo and you had one shot yeah
if you if you blinked or if you have
braces you had to wait till next October
yeah the next photo and I'm always like
gotta get this right and I get so
anxious of getting it right that I
scrunch up my face and then and they
start yelling at you
thank you yell we can't please everybody
cool you yeah and they always go turn
around
yeah and it's a trick and I'll turn
around and do my corny like Olin Mills
thing I'm listening to you or they'll be
like blow a kiss you're like no oh no
they try to trap you yeah into doing
something and there's that awkward like
you're blowing a kiss to know why oh why
so dumb I remember I heard a friend of
mine stylist Jennifer Lopez and said
that she looked down until she's ready
so they can't get a photo she just looks
at the ground maybe that works for her
like she called me has like three
bodyguards around it it would just be
like are they looking at their breasts
she asleep is something wrong Kate ovals
herself look at her she's like yeah like
she's like a wall of humans that are
blocking her from getting her photo eyes
they'd be like I think like something's
wrong it's like 17
she Amano not now not now maybe I got
Whitney such a bitch like that would be
the photo everywhere like bending over
single my gray hairs yeah here like a
bald spot I always have to do like the
boob check before I go on the red carpet
and that's what I do I might get really
close to me so all like the people human
Walt yeah hard me so I can to get but
you have like a like a whole plan before
you out there I don't know if I have a
plan but I just like what this pose
looks best with this dress and doesn't
make me look fat yeah I would say half
the people on social media that aren't
in our business are better at posing
wait at our this point just go went to
college with in Tallahassee really
nailed it like please help me but uh
that party was was crazy because I
always get seated I looking back like
there's all these seating charts and you
go in and you learn like your place in
the business you learn your stuff like
you go to these parties and there's also
a time they give you yeah the Vanity
Fair party you get a time you have to
show up at a certain time and the time
is the first indicator of what your
value is in the business and then you
get seated next to certain people I was
seated next to Brett Ratner they always
put me next to the perverts they're like
she can handle it but I think the cool
person in my table was Judd Apatow yeah
and then I think maybe that's how I met
you
yeah yes I yeah I you know love to third
wheel with Japanese lady that's right
and I remember when I met you being
annoyed because I was like oh I love her
and I'm I don't have room for more
friends I remember going like no the
answer's no you're not you can't do this
like you can't you're no new
applications no new friends I can't see
in the ones I had and then I was just
like Bach she's so like funny and cool
and I guess we have to be friends
and I also loved you because you this
word gets turn around a lot but you
really were like a girl's girl to me
like a lot of people go to that party
and they're trying to like get the
producers to think a certain thing or if
like you were just there to like have a
good time and you were just like hanging
out with girls and like
drunk on the balcony I was like she's
Rahway I don't have any movies no no I
mean I love girlfriends I think it's so
important I you know have two sisters
strong I love other sister I've got to
spend time with you and your sister and
you're so cute together I know they're
yeah my sister's like my lifeline she's
my first best friend but yeah I just you
know you raised in a family full of
women like you know the value of women
friendship yeah you're so you're so good
at them and and we've got and you're
also a really good friend because I
think I'm learning as an adult the best
friends in your life are the ones that
you can like not see for a couple months
and when you see each other you pick
right back up yeah I mean when you have
like friends that are everywhere you
just get you you have to have that it's
too exhausting like start from the
beginning yeah after you haven't seen
someone in a while until not like keep
score me like how about your where are
you I haven't seen you hey stranger like
that kind of passive-aggressive stuff
when friends you know keep a score sheet
that is just gets so frustrated yeah cuz
you get older I so agree just don't have
a good time
you also cracked me up one time we were
having dinner before one of these big
Hollywood parties which I think they're
called parties they shouldn't be called
parties there are auditions yeah they're
always auditions
they're always it's like I'm always like
I feel like I'm being judged at these
parties cuz I was being judged I'd yeah
I was a comical party
it's all the people that could employ
you and but then they never like
employee from that party because they're
all drunk just wanting a night away it's
it really is just to see how you're up
keeping yourself yeah you said something
you probably don't even remember this is
after you got married and you're going
to some one of these like Golden Globes
parties and I was like I just can't do
it this year and you went oh I'm only
going to let them know I'm not pregnant
okay because as soon as you get married
everyone's like oh she wants that white
picket fence life cuz she's not working
anymore probably pregnant like you were
like I'm just showing up to let people
know that you can get married and not be
pregnant yeah
and and I just was like oh yeah that's
what you do you just go to these parties
to let people know like I'm available I
cut my hair yeah I can play the best
friend in your movie exactly you're just
going to like check in I remember I was
with a director once and we were at some
premiere and a famous actress ran up to
him and just went hey how are you so
good to see you and ran off and he went
she wanted me to know she lost her baby
weight that's what he said he's gay so
maybe it's not as as shallow but uh and
he's like now I know like she's back
she's back
it's brutal I mean it's brutal it's a
little Sparty's what's the baby way
thing I also have a story about you that
you probably don't know before I met you
I was dating someone it was a very
unhealthy relationship anyway I don't
know if you know but I've been in a
couple of those I was probably 28 is my
guess doesn't excuse my behavior it's
still too old to be this way it was just
a really unhealthy relationship and you
know those like toxic relationships who
were kind of in in our 20s where
everything was a thing and it was before
I understood that you can be in a
relationship with someone and it's
actually healthy for the person you're
with to be able to like say oh yeah that
girl's prettier you don't have to be you
know ridiculous about it but I know you
look at other women yeah I know that
it'd be weird to not think a pretty girl
is pretty and if you and we do it with
we do yeah but even women yeah it's
human nature and exactly why are we all
pretending that we have blinders and
it's that it doesn't have to be a sexual
thing it can also just be an
appreciation like also I feel like with
other women you know they they put in
time like notice it that's such a great
way to put it I've never thought of it
that way but this is when you were just
getting really famous and I think it was
a Vanity Fair cover maybe and and you
were on the cover and everybody was
talking about you and your body he was
just like you were having that huge sort
of like introductory moment yeah and you
were on the cover of an affair and the
guy was at the time he just looks at me
he goes see that's what men want Oh God
that we know that's what we want they
finally figured it out them yeah a
picture on a magazine who doesn't speak
just one photo like but she doesn't want
you yeah you know when you just get
jealous and I just was like but you're
not she's not in the running for you
like I it was this thing where I was
like but she's not available to you
like I just we've all done that like
childish immature thing but it was his
way of just saying like why his fashion
only put anorexic people and covers of
magazines for so long guys yeah into
that you know and that's what we want
and women aren't into that either like
the marketing's telling us that we're
into that before not like we want I mean
I I know I did
I wanted to appreciate my body and just
be as fit as I could be like no one
wants to walk in a room and feel less
than then somebody in your image that's
perfect because they're anorexic or just
naturally super thin so I think it's
important that we're all just the best
version of ourselves and we can
appreciate each other's bodies and
differences did that feel like did you
know that you were walking into being
like a body like positivity progress
icon when all that was happening no yeah
no I worked really really hard to be
super thin at the beginning of my career
because that's what you know I was a
working model and I was successful
working model and then I got these
awesome opportunities and I didn't know
that I was considered like the maybe I
told me girl your back and I was like we
right starving myself and if I'm already
fat so I had like I went on a real
journey of like finding how to
appreciate my body and my differences
and what that meant to me personally and
then all Y all while being in the
spotlight and people pushing me to be
the leader in this movement
because you're a - instead of a zero
yeah literally I mean literally but ya
know and then but I feel like as I was
talking about it I was also working
through it and I think that that's why
it came up as authentic as it was hmm
like as I was trying to figure out my
place and how I felt about being judged
for my body realizing I don't I don't
give a shit what people say about my
body because this is my body and taking
care of it puts me in a confident mental
position to take that stand like I know
I fueled my body properly and I worked
out and I did enjoy that chocolate and I
don't really care if you say I shouldn't
have had it because I did and I feel
good about myself yeah I mean it's just
been it's it's been so I do think it was
like such a big it started such a big
thing yeah when I think about these
conversations that people are having and
how ad campaigns are changing and how
sizing is changing for lots of brands I
mean that is kind of when it started in
a way right yeah I mean that's how I
guess the conversation started and I
mean obviously people wanted it that's
why the conversation started it wasn't
because you know I was there it was
because people were yearning for
differences yeah and at the time I
started modeling it was you know no one
had the voice to say what they wanted
because there was no social media now
people can say no no represented this is
what I want so only designers were
leading that charge and they were like
we want something different someone who
looks perfect but like an alien that's
literally what they would say and being
like meetings say yeah they wanted the
perfect features but put together in an
alien like way like the perfect big eyes
the perfect big lips but not put
together right this is alarming
yeah a lot of people don't even know
about how why models are they it this
started in during World War two I
actually weirdly wrote a paper on this
Dollard about where because I struggled
with eating stuff for so long I think I
got obsessed we have the origin of where
this super impossibly thin body type
came from and it came
a shortage of fabric in the 50s when
world war ii happened basically the
design is real we don't have enough
fabric so we'll just make them smaller
and smaller and it wasn't supposed to
stay like that it was just essentially
how they coped with the shortage of
fabric in the 50s Benton are you nodding
yeah thank you and and then it just kind
of stuck and that just became the
standard of beauty from just an accident
and also Marilyn Monroe was also thin
that's the other thing she literally
like well Marilyn robotic Tubman but she
was an 8 she lived in an 8 oh yeah they
were like no even smaller they're like
she's a size 12 but the sizing was
different back then she was a 2/4 wild
wild it was just different sizing it's
like in the UK it was similar sizing to
that right because of to here is like an
ad like that do you get sick of talking
about it
about my body yeah I mean I think yes
and no I get really sick about talking
about I look like guys and creepy ways
but in this way no I talk about it all
day because I want to spread a positive
message for other women I think we all
should own our bodies and feel good
about talking about it in ways that we
we own no and we feel proud of but I
guess I get sick of of marketing I mean
like why are you guys talking about it
like that
yeah like come on just don't make it a
thing just hire the right person no
matter their body type or represent
different people and don't do it just as
a trendy thing do it as something that's
going to stay I'm trying to think if I
knew you before you and your husband
started dating I feel like I did and I'm
fascinated because I'm I don't even
remember meeting Cara Lee I was anyway
Brett Ratner too because i reaiiy i love
your relationship because it's weird
when you see a friend with somebody and
you just know like oh that's a
they're gonna marry do you know what I
mean yeah you I feel like you always
know before your friend knows yeah that
make any sense yeah you just feel it you
just feel it and you're like she might
not even know this yet but they're for
sure this is gonna happen yeah like I
just know it and this is I've seen my
friend before this person I've seen my
friend during this person and this is
the best version of her yeah and you
also like when you met Justin you
created a friendship with him right away
- well I loved him I loved him
I eyed him and I just get along really
well I don't know why yeah I don't know
why he's very he kind of is like he's
very funny and and clear and maybe all
great athletes I think have to be this
like I he's very clear he's very honest
with himself he's very self-aware
yeah and he fucking calls it like yes
and I just love that kind of personality
yeah me too cuz you know where you stand
yeah it's no bullshit you just have fun
with them but I do remember going like
this is gonna be a rough road like
they're two very strong I'm very curious
to see how these arguments go because
both people are probably very good at
winning Justin's not someone that likes
to lose yeah yeah I would imagine and I
remember you said something where you
were like we're what is it called a
power struggle yes yeah the power
struggle face what is it when in a
relationship does that happen it can I
mean I guess it's just different for any
relationship I think it's like from the
very beginning like two or three months
to two years or something oh interesting
but yeah it's just the it's the phase
after the honeymoon phase or the
romantic maze whatever you want to call
it where you see that person as perfect
and you guys become one and then in this
power struggle phase you from my
understanding of it what happens is that
I win yeah that's how I win the pattern
oh that you're almost trying to find
nature it's Nature's Way of you finding
your own personality and balance inside
the relationship you're not one your own
independent exact in a unit you start
seeing all their flaws
course on purpose start triggering them
and like provoking that so that you can
be like they're not perfect see and and
you're separating from them a little bit
because you want to balance out the
power and from like my understanding
when you first hear power struggle you
think you're in a power struggle with
each other but for me it was more like a
power struggle with yourself like
understanding that you're doing this
inside their relationship and just
trying to stir up shit so that you don't
entirely lose yourself or lead identity
exactly Asian ship yeah and once we kind
of realize that that's what was
happening that we were having a stupid
fight hmm we were able to communicate
through it you know just to be like oh
I'm feeling vulnerable or scared or this
is you know in this situation I'm
feeling triggered because it's that
moment in the relationship where you're
like I need to give up time whether it's
in my career or with my friendships to
support him or him with me I'm giving
you so much yeah and I have to make sure
this is worth it exactly and for me that
was my thing but everybody has their own
triggers whether you know from a past
relationship or whatever it is that I
think about it all the time because I'm
fascinating that moment in relationship
where you're completely enamored with
someone you're obsessed with them and
then you're just like the fucking Cup
yeah here's to leave the fuckin Cup on
table it is not going to just the cup
that cup weird it's not about the cup
yeah you're like why are we arguing
about this cuz it's crazy it's obviously
just about me I'm trying to test you to
make sure yeah all these sacrifices I'm
making or worth it or and just coming
out of this like this days that you're
like this is the perfect human and then
you're like he's not perfect because he
put the fucking cup here and I would
have never done that I mean that strong
psychopath I know I found myself doing
that in relationships but I think that
that often happens when it's kind of for
lack of a bird
better bird for lack of the bird for
lack of a better word it's the one and
you're kind of I think all this shared
scared here starts coming in and this is
now the father
future child yeah and so I know in
relationships that you know it's going
great and then all of a sudden I'll be
like so you're just not gonna wear the
headphones on the podcast so when we
have kids you're just not gonna put the
seat belt on
no I so I think you're not gonna wear
your seat belt what happens when we have
a kid
you're not like everything becomes such
a bigger thing well and and the fact is
like and we talked about this all the
time they have so much power really
because you just gave your heart to them
and so you trying to fight for your
power back isn't gonna happen because
you were totally vulnerable and gave
them your heart and now you realize wow
I'm in a situation where I could be
severely hurt and that's gonna that's
gonna fuck up my day you know the power
struggle oddly is you're powerless and
you have to ask cope with exactly this
person could level you it anymore
exactly and you just have to be
vulnerable with each other and trust
each other and Trust is so hard oh my
gosh it's so real yep but also there's
this thing where you're like it's too
late like the and the power struggle
you're like what are we doing you're
like no matter addicted to me I expected
to you're gonna be hurt so might as well
just give over the trust I think it's
trying to control the way we get yeah or
something so let me just start that shit
yeah and then so now you got you don't
have that anymore
you're just like whatever no yeah we
definitely worked through that anyway so
if like that guy we definitely worked
through that and but it was real I did
you find out about that was a book or
something we just started we got in a
big fight over nothing and they were
like what do we do we um well why are we
arguing I'm so fired and then yeah and
so then we started like researching it
and being more aware and we're just you
know worked on our communication we're
done like letting the part of the other
person know when we were feeling that
when we were feeling vulnerable or
whatever that was and then I'm also
laughing because I know you well enough
to know I do feel like it it's very hard
for you if you're annoyed to hide it
oh I can't I think you I'm like a glass
house you really are because like so
many of these little micro fights and
relationships just come from like yeah
sure yeah and then that's a two day
fight like you your eyes are so
expensive like I've just seen you in
situations where you're just like like I
can't I don't even I can't get out of my
own way the listeners really can't see
what I'm doing but you can say so much
with just like it's really hard for you
to get around that I think so many of
our little fights that we have are just
from little shit like that yeah that's
why I'm just like I know that about
myself and I'm just so direct and so
honest yeah I'm super annoyed but it's
okay or like a lot of times you know
being long-distance we just have really
bad FOMO Oh God oh my God he's having so
much fun without me this awesome dinner
that I would have be at yeah and we just
call it out we're like I want I wish I
was there I was there and I'm probably
not gonna be supportive about your
awesome time you're about to have yeah
let's go yeah have fun I'm gonna be
super aggressive next couple hours yeah
but it's just cuz I like I want to be
there with you all that love is yeah
sort of
is um I love long distance what are your
like how do you manage it is there like
a daily schedule of like we have to talk
every day we have to FaceTime every day
no because I mean when you're in
different time zones that's just
impossible we just are aware that if we
don't talk consistently for let's say I
don't even know they like five days we
start bickering we get starts yup start
missing each other up and and then we
just you know carve out that time or
just are aware and again just call it
out yeah I just miss you
yeah and I'm fuck you yeah I miss you
I want a new skill I want you to have
more skills - I'm gonna get one with
Skillshare think about that you need to
explore some new skills deepen your
existing passion get ting some online
classes what skill share classes are you
gonna take I don't to take painting I
want to get lost in creativity I want
you to paint me I will paint you I'll
paint you like a French girl I want you
to do a portrait of me and all the dogs
make it yeah okay good I know how to
paint nipple so this will be great I
want to learn I saw a girl on Instagram
who made a sweater out of her dog's hair
mmm hate her I wonder if she has a class
for that it's an online learning
community where millions come together
to take the next step in their creative
journey thousands of inspiring classes
probably not the dog here creative and
curious people on topics including
illustration design photography video
freelancing and more it's very
affordable especially when you compare
it to pricy in-person classes annual
subscription is less than ten dollars a
month
Skillshare is a proud sponsor of good
for you explore your creativity at
skills chair comm slash good for you get
two free months of premium membership
that's two whole months of unlimited
access to thousands of classes not the
dog hair one for free get started and
joined today by heading to Skillshare
comm slash good for you Skillshare comm
slash good for you tired of feeling
self-conscious in photos why not make
this the year to straighten out them
teeth I thought it's gonna be spine no
candid delivers clear liners directly it
strains your teeth so that you're not
running around looking like a jackal a
no yeah looking like Pennywise out there
your tinder profile pictures you know
the gutter strain your teeth but it's
sixty-five less than braces unlike
braces candid clear aligners are
comfortable removable and totally
invisible
unlike the clear braces I got when I was
ten that didn't work at all I wear mine
around just because they're a sponsor
you have clear liners they just name
hashtag Adam just on them like your
grill unlike other companies candid only
works with orthodontist never general
random-ass dentist off the street that
means your treatment will be designed by
an expert in tooth movement with twenty
years of experience on average so are
you ready to take the next step towards
straighter teeth for a limited time you
can get started with $75 off by using
the code Whitney at candid co.com slash
Whitney that's candid cocom / whitney
use the code whitney for $75 off get
those street in order those streets
those get those teeth on the street
rosen order candid code calm / whitney
code whitney i remember when you're
planning your wedding that was really
exhausting for you you know I hate
wedding planning well that I mean some
people know that's already that I'm I'm
not engaged at the moment because it was
it was truly so hard for me I comes
really easy to a lot of people I'm just
not good with a lot of little decisions
and I had a really hard time with who do
I invite who do I know I don't want to
hurt this person oh my god and then
everyone everyone's advice to you is
like it's your wedding do whatever you
want you're like no but after the
wedding I'm gonna have to face that
friend and I don't want to lose friends
over that and this just turned into
another $50,000 big if I invite this
person I have to invite everyone from
high school ah fine by this passion from
college everyone's gonna know what
social media has now made it so you
cannot have a 50 person and it's like it
also depends on like what number you are
in the family of getting married like if
you're one of the first and your family
of getting married like everyone assumes
everyone's invited everyone assumes that
everybody gets a plus-one oh gosh and
you're just like like for my sister
that's how it was for her and and just
so many people were mad at her where I
was like way down the list of cousins
getting married so everyone was more
forgiving they're like yep she can't you
can't invite everyone it's fine your
sisters cut it took the bullet up yeah
what was your rule on Plus once it was
yeah no ring no brain you and you do get
like that cousin near the end you're
like I don't want to be dealing with
this list you should like sharpening out
people or if if Justin and I hung out
with them as a couple a lot a lot good
rule then they were invited a friend of
mine did one
Italy also that was you have to have met
the parents in on a trip together and
said I love you I'm like did you ask
so are you like calling your friend
you're like so did you what where was
the trip how far away was it how many
day and then they're just like love you
I love you that known each other for
three weeks so that might not be a very
good and also people like you lose
friends over the wedding because you see
like nasty sides of people who do we're
suddenly there's anything crazy yeah
they're like oh you know I just started
dating this girl for two weeks but and
I'm going through a divorce but like my
dad got cancer so and she helped me
through it so she deserves to go and
you're like I don't know this girl I
don't want to know anything about that
right now has nothing to do with my
wedding and like you were barely invited
you're pushing it but also yeah it's
like it is wild because I found that
when I started the process everyone puts
their stuff on you know yeah everyone
everyone puts her stuff and that's
ultimately why I depress pause it was
like you know I have like lots of like
sick family members and want people I
haven't talked to and it was like I
haven't seen you in so long
you know like I have to this is such a
big deal we're gonna be flying out and
you're stuck oh no I wasn't even gonna
invite you literally you're like whoo
and then people that you are like kind
of like like ancillary friends will ask
you lots of questions about the wedding
and you're like what Alaska me now I
have to invite you like sending you
venue ideas and you're like oh well and
the closer it gets to the date the more
guilty you feel you go through all these
different phases we're like savage you
know marking out people and then
suddenly you're like I've talked too
much about my wedding to this person
like I have you have to like them so
then you invite them or they keep asking
asking stop ask some you get yourself
invited also a wedding suck why do you
wanna go I do find though that for a lot
of people that have been married for a
while like weddings are their fun thing
to do
where they you know can leave their kids
with a sitter and I'm like oh you need
this way more than I did yeah and also I
learned that Justin was zero help in the
wedding planning process because he
works all summer long he never goes to
weddings he had no idea what goes into a
wedding he's like honey why can't we
invite my entire team all of their
spouses and then every single person
like what do you mean there's a limit of
people we can have you're like okay
never mind you're not a lot of you
involved yeah what are you talking about
I mean how many people would that be I I
mean I'm alone we there's like a
thousand people on a baseball team yeah
there's so many people in the field it's
okay it's and it's just totally
different from a party and you just
assume it's like a party I don't know no
there's so many logistics involved did
you have any friends that you feel like
you kind of lost in the process oh yeah
Wow yeah because you really you really
see who they are and you see at the
ceremony I've seen so many friendships
dissolved because of someone's behavior
at the ceremony when you were like oh
you just couldn't not make this night
about you yeah you just couldn't yeah I
feel like ultimately we had a great
group of people that did come what now
you got there yeah and that's the great
thing about I wasn't there so it kind of
been that good but okay yeah you were
invited I couldn't come because I've
like no it was a it was like a whole
yeah yeah I'm like don't worry about it
and but yeah it was a great the vows
renewal and like that was ultimately the
final straw was like when I look around
I don't want to see people that I don't
know and I don't want to introduce
myself at my own wedding yeah and that's
kind of where the line was I don't want
to introduce myself at my own wedding
that's such a good one yeah I got a text
once from a friend of mine who's like we
had like you a monthly game night I'd
see him like once a month we didn't
really talk outside of that game night
but we were really like good friends and
I got a text from him one day he was
like hey such a good friend I love you
just want you to know it's gonna be a
small wedding I can't invite everyone
and I just wanted you to hear it first I
loved it it was such a great text I was
just like made me like him more I mean
I'm relieved when I'm done me to go
great I was like thank you
how you give just as a thank you I
thought that was such a classy way to
handle it and he told me later that he
made a list of all the people he
couldn't invite and just sent them that
text and he said that it was like 90%
success rate of people not getting
shitty about it I killed me you're like
10% we're shitty I get 10% virginity
he's like I'm just trying to do the
right thing sure yeah but then I also
had a cousin who who's like only invited
to the rehearsal dinner like one cousin
everyone was invited to ceremony
everyone flew in and then only invited
my brother to his rehearsal dinner and
you're like just don't invite my brother
yeah yeah like just make clear lines
clear lines cuz then everyone's like I
didn't even want to go to your rehearsal
dinner but now I'm just mad that I'm
even here that I even flew in what was
your favorite wedding gift you got I
hate buy wedding gifts because I never
know if I'm doing well like what's a
good one what's the best wedding gift
that I got well I put it on my registry
I got a Roomba but I just
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Rodney Dangerfield did you give me your
emphysema or whatever probably that's so
funny you have a Roomba zooming around
your house oh love it and then I
returned some of the games people got me
and bought another room but you know you
got a dog yeah that's such a god I'm
constantly I have a sciatica from
cleaning up dog oh yeah I put one in my
living room one in my bedroom now I'm
gonna get one for the baby's room do
they know when to just go you it's all
on an app you just click it and it goes
does your dog chase it no I just told
him not to you know he's so good yeah I
know I know I know I'm I don't know
we're gonna get the Harley okay I know
he's like a little human but uh you know
what's so weird I was trying to write a
joke about this in my last special is
that when a Roomba gets stuck under a
couch you know when it gets stuck and
it's trying to get I feel bad for it
yeah isn't that weird
nice like emotionally attached to them
because they like because when you see
him get stuck you're like Oh buddy
meanwhile I'm like what do you mean I
have to walk over there and get you out
of there I would never think of getting
someone a Roomba oh love it that's so
funny it's just like so so but going
like you're lazy yeah literally a
terrible way no I forgot about rumbas I
didn't realize they were still happening
oh yeah and then now the new ones they
go back to their little pod and they
empty themselves and then go back to the
exact spot they left that creeps me out
that's like some black mirror don't you
have a robot like I don't know why it
has like eyeballs and looks like me on
five minutes if it's in my spitting
image okay with that obviously it's the
bass and then so was your pregnancy
plant gift of life that's weird
I I have like a couple weird skills I'm
not good at a lot of things the guys in
this room know I'm very bad at a lot of
things but what I'm good at something
I'm really good at it and something I'm
really good at is guessing names baby
names I know by the way I keep moving in
this chair I know you're not even I'm
like you've rolled like a higher over
there modeling I'm weirdly good at
guessing baby dance I didn't guess the
exact name of your baby no but I guessed
my guess you guess basically the
nickname yes I was gonna was I think it
was like Viviana or something yeah like
you're gonna name your baby Viviana and
you were like is Viviana your name like
I remember your face getting like really
serious yeah because our her she's
Genevieve and her nicknames Vivi yeah it
was very close yeah yeah yeah that's
right because I was like vivvy vivvy and
I think Vivian was my gassers yapping in
that area no it was Vivian I barely
and then what we're you don't have to
tell me but who did I ask this I think I
don't remember who I asked this was it
Bilborough
we think was burr that what were your
runner-up names um I'm obsessed with
naming things yeah unless you're gonna
use them for no no we like Vivian we
talked about Vivian and then we talked
about I don't know what we talked about
I don't even remember we need to get you
some ginkgo biloba pills or something
baby you forget a lot if you find that
your memory is going when you got
pregnant no literally I used to have the
best memory and now I'm like on the
struggle bus tastes terrible they start
eating your brain I think that yeah
taking brain cells and Dawson has a
terrible memory so he's like this is how
I've always felt you just walking around
having no yeah or like did you have an
easy pregnancy or a hard one you know I
I think overall I have no complaints but
I have every complaint like being
pregnant is hard yeah it's just I can't
even carry luggage in the airport you I
mean you are a passenger yeah on this
ride your body has taken over and it's
really awesome but you have like no
control even walking a couple blocks
late in my pregnancy I was like swollen
and everything hurt it's just it's wild
yeah but you have like some kind of like
endorphins get you through it I think I
mean you just got stuck so yes was that
guy of the earth process painful I mean
that's a crazy question I know some
women like I loved it I want to do it
again
like I'm addicted to it it's also good
found my purpose no that's why yeah I
definitely had an epidural but I also
had I had a great birth I did you know
any photos it was just fast oh good yeah
it was very fast and then did you just
you knew and another thing I think they
don't tell a lot of people friends am i
recently that I've been pregnant like
they don't tell you that not everyone's
water breaks yeah in movies you learn
that like you saw so they don't tell you
that when your water breaks it can be
hours
hours and hours it doesn't come out
right after the water breaks that's just
the start of it huh also they don't tell
you it's not nine months it's ten months
oh oh yeah and everyone's like how do
you leave my nine nine and so did you
like right away now cuz you're so you're
such a clear person and you'd plate like
you're so like decisive did you just
like no know what that I hear like I'm
itsgotime no okay so I did not know and
my mom and my sister both had similar
birth experiences and I don't know why I
didn't believe them but like we have
this apparently like in our genetics
this thing where we don't feel the
contractions until like eight
centimeters dilated so my mom all four
pregnancies she didn't get an epidural
cuz was too late back then oh god I had
it like the most amazing doctor and
she's like I don't care I'll give it to
you but yeah so I like I felt the
contractions but I was like isn't is
that a contraction so they what does it
feel like just like pressure mm-hmm yeah
just pressure yeah I just feel like and
also a lot of my friends who are like
I've been in so much pain all my life
just being a woman that childbirth I
like cuz I was like that cramps is that
a back it's a migraine it's to get
always in some kind of pain and then
right before childbirth everybody talks
about like I don't want to poop in front
of my husband and I want to be like
pooping is the most normal thing to do
like the fact that a baby is coming out
of you is that's that's the thing that's
not normal to see you know I love to
talk about poop birthing a child let my
body do what she do there's also blood
and skin Terry yeah a friend of mine
yeah a friend of my tour real bad Oh
friend of mine too oh gosh they don't
tell you about that do they no but you
know if they did if people talked about
that no one like our species would go
extinct no one would continue on but no
one really talks about breastfeeding
after that's the hardest thing to know
in the entire world everyone thinks it's
so natural like it's the most natural
thing to do it's impossible yeah it's
really hard for so hard to fake the
baby's figuring out
the nipple you're figuring out the
nipple you're so tired you're shamed if
you can't do it right you're shamed if
you put up like boundaries and then
there's this whole thing of like you
never know if you're giving the baby
enough food or with a bottle you know
exactly how much food the baby so then
you're always in the mom shame you're
like I'm eating the baby okay by feeding
him too much not enough and so I feel
like breastfeeding really covered up the
birth experience I'm like I'd do the
birth experience again but breastfeeding
these we talked about that is so hard
and it's not natural and it takes like
take 17 classes before but that's so
interested there's a breastfeeding class
because a friend of mine she had to get
a lactation consultant yes-no get
definitely get those cuz she could not
do it and I think getting so embarrassed
in a shame that you can't started
stressing her out so much because the
baby screaming and all you want to do is
feed beautiful baby you guys created and
you don't know how and the baby doesn't
know how and it hurts and you're
bleeding and it's it's chapped it's
purple why do not people not talk about
this more I don't know I think it's too
real Kimberly can we look up how what
percentage of women struggle with
lactation or breastfeeding yeah and I
think there's this ridiculous that we're
like you have to breastfeed it's deal
it's the eye contact people to
understand it's the eye contact that
they get from breastfeeding that's
important which you can also do with the
bottle you can do with formula oh yeah I
think that's a thing too is like
breastfeeding didn't give me the bond
with my baby like she's my baby
I could I could have not carried her and
not breastfed her and I'd still love her
more than anything in the world like
breastfeeding her didn't make me love
her more yeah it was impossible to love
her right oh that's but yeah I mean the
screaming at me while breastfeeding that
was tough that's traumatizing yeah and
what did you do um you know I got real
stubborn moms didn't everyone around me
was like you know they're trying to be
supportive and being like everyone's got
so much advice so much advice when
you're a new mom and you can't even like
lock into your own instincts which are
all there
yeah because everyone's giving you
advice yeah that I kind of I kind of
left my body because I was like I've got
to figure this out I have to I have to
figure it out and then I
it was like in the shame where I was
like some women can't even produce milk
I have so much milk I could literally
feed a village I should use the cartons
of milk apparently they were built for
function two guys they were all thought
for a long time like that baby's gonna
eat well but really breast size has
nothing to do with breast feeding and a
lot of women go in like already scared
if they don't have like large breasts or
whatever it has nothing to do with it
it's about your body and what it's
producing that is so stressful then
ultimately were people helpful yeah I
mean it's just so hard to know how like
now even now I'm like I don't I don't
know how to help a friend because every
experience is so different see this is
why I think you're gonna like just
continue to be like such a influential
voice cuz you just say I don't know yeah
it's so many people go here's what you
do and this is the exact shit that
causes shame and confusion in people and
self-doubt is that so many people
pretend that they're experts in
everyone's experience yeah it's that
people go well she said that this works
for everyone and it's not working for me
and I'm too embarrassed to even ask
about it every baby is so different like
some babies I know my sisters first
child breastfed so easy everything was
easy and it was easier to breastfeed
than make a bottle yeah because
everything just worked and her second
baby it didn't go the same way and you
know I thought it would and she tried it
to fit those two experiences into the
same mold you know didn't happen that
way and it's like you feel shame and I
want to give both babies the same
advantages but ultimately we're all
doing our best we just gotta stop
judging each other
my mom was drinking when she breasts
yeah I'm fine like the father you don't
have been fine I know and I have fake
boobs and I went I was like my email to
breast feed they're like it's fine I was
like why are you sure in the cast like
also I'm like Jake oh no jaqen was
formula-fed like he's one of the top
athletes they shouldn't maybe there's
something to that
like the face of formula haha holy shit
that's true and then anything that goes
wrong with your child I mean okay maybe
not anything all these doctors are gonna
be like well like your doctor
immediately recommends formula like if
your baby has anything jaundice or isn't
gaining enough weight through a formula
what I thought breastfeeding was the
best now they're recommending formula no
one knows nobody knows that's the thing
nobody knows and every baby's different
so study I'm stop pretending the yeah oh
my god we're judging just let just write
it out did you work out during your
pregnancy I saw some yeah I did my best
got like I do my best
yeah I did and it's like I think the
hardest thing is post pregnancy I was
like I gotta get right back in the gym I
have to jump right back you know there's
so much pressure to bounce back you know
all these women like we have to be
exactly what we were alike as quickly as
possible before and and then the media I
feel like have the media that's the
oldest thing I've ever said but like
some people will be like here here's
so-and-so four weeks after having her by
now it's like stop making that a
headline like it's job and exceeds nine
trainers and she always looked like this
she's 21 just why is this a news story
yeah and again everyone's different like
maybe you ripped more than the other
person maybe your hormones are more
intent like my hormones were way more
intense
well breastfeeding then I was pregnant
huh so I I was like more swollen more
exhausted while I was breastfeeding it's
not necessary to also add in the
pressure of trying to be exactly what I
looked like before right and it was
pressure I put on myself for sure and
messaging I put on out there - yeah you
were I was like close together whoa no
but yeah I just feel like it the infant
phase - flies by so just like give
yourself a break we all will get back in
the gym it doesn't doesn't um I read
somewhere the breastfeeding burns
calories is that sure I don't it didn't
for me it did it for me yeah and I have
a whole theory that it's all
because every one of my friends who
bounced back after pregnancy they all
formula-fed they love breastfeed and all
of my friends who are breastfeeding
we're all swollen and holding on to the
extra weight because you also require
more calories to breastfeed Oh see I see
there's a lot of this shit that doesn't
add up for me and I don't like I don't
like any of these um pseudoscience sort
of like arrogant theories like yeah the
broad generalizations you're aiming
women about like not using you know meds
to give birth or having a home birth
like I talked to a pediatric
anesthesiologist who's like half of the
horrible things we see in the ER with
babies or from home births like this is
not a game can you imagine the cleanup
on a home like who's doing the cleanup
not me just like there's this thing now
where you can't just go to a doctor and
use the latest technology yeah everyone
wants to go back to being Amish
I mean it's who there's definitely like
there's trust that's been lost in all
that Authority yeah yeah and there are
bad doctors I again the best doctor I
was like wow this is amazing
everyone was like who cares no fat
shaming cuz there's doctors with fat
shame you too there's also doctors who
when I froze my eggs they say and this
is I know this is true and I I'm
actually split on this but they're like
well cuz yours would be a geriatric
pregnancy at any pregnancy over 30 yeah
I think it's geriatric which is I'm just
in your high-risk immediately yes and
which that's them doing their job and
the science does back up that is yeah
but you know return I'm just like can we
get a synonym in there for that yeah how
about just like a career woman pregnancy
yeah nothing like someone who you know a
fucker woman with a 401k pregnancy I
worked you know that's why there's a
little delay
alright guys I know a lot of podcasters
they're out there shilling a bunch of
products that they don't really use
they're out there saying they use
products they're full of shit
I'm not look at this I'm wearing my me
undies right now look look at you now
what now what daliyah
now what rogen you really wearing me
undies I just proved it and if you're
not watching on YouTube you probably
have no idea what just happened I showed
my me undies to everyone show my really
use these I'm not a shill yeah call them
out drag them since these are the best
underwear I swear to god you got a best
you got them for me well you got me some
non me undies first and I went to the
mall for one you got a store hoppin
these granny panties that look like a
Viking shorts they were full coverage
okay well they look like a bandage
it was awful and then the me undies
they're so soft that they they feel like
skin they feel you're the best underwear
I got him for years I get what Hannibal
Lecter was talking about I get it
he would love these I love mine they're
very soft they're very smooth sometimes
I forgot I'm wearing him I almost peed
right through him the other day I love
me undies I'm a big fan me too I remind
everywhere I wear mine and all
throughout my apartment people don't
like it I do it anyways I go
door-to-door everyone in your in your
apartment complex yeah which ones you
wear I wear the I were the little
bikinis in class excuse me I wear
panties there were a whole panties I bet
you're odd news might be smaller than
Miami undies there's a great offer for
my listeners any first-time purchases
you're gonna get 15% off and free
shipping this is a no-brainer especially
because they have a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee I'm wearing them
right now right this minute you
satisfied I'm very satisfied there you
go feel a thing get your 15 percent off
your first pair free shipping a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee
Mia news.com slash Whitney Mia nice calm
Whitney
today tix they figured it out finally a
freaking company made it so you can buy
tickets to shows plays music without
getting scalped or scalper wait no
scalpers whatever get it all in one
place all in one place ok it's just such
a better way to buy tickets they've got
just the best prices
on shows all in one place you just get
the app or go to todaytix comm I'm on
the site right now it's all just right
here yeah that's what I want I want to
be able to get my tickets to hairspray
for student Galera and wrassling all in
one place wrassling wrastlin are you or
do you like do you enjoy the wrassling
if I can get a ticket for that sure
we'll make it easy and I'll go I'm gonna
go see rent I want to see when rents in
town 525 those and some gym units
anywhere you live it's not just Broadway
not just London's West End tickets
everywhere chicagee Los Angeles
Washington DC San Francisco Sydney more
today tix.com finally see that show
you've been wanting to see forever
Benton Chippendales or discover
something new that you'll love just as
much go to today tix.com / Whitney
you'll use promo code Whitney to get $10
off your first todaytix purchase you're
welcome
promo code Whitney todaytix t IX dot-com
/ Whitney for $10 off your first ticket
purchase go see wicked live your life
today tix.com / Whitney Celine Dion here
we go but I just feel like there's so
many fake rules that are just now making
people feel shame yeah about what
happens I know yeah and as soon as you
lose trust in one area you lose trust in
the whole thing and also I think this is
maybe a weird thing to say but if your
doctor if your if your doctors not
communicating with you or not just get a
new one like get a new line oh my god
that's what I said yeah I say to
everyone like if you don't if you don't
feel right get a new doctor I think a
lot of us think like but if you're with
you have 10 months yeah you have 10
months they can just fax I guess not
faxing more I think I was just I was
just at the dog vet for fight they can
carrier pigeon your Scrolls over to the
ye olde hospital yeah I was just I think
that for me I was going this is
obviously a very different situation I'm
one of those people that is gonna have
someone talk about their baby and I'm
gonna talk about my dog
I think it's I yeah I didn't it it
I actually argue sometimes dogs are
harder because they can't talk to you
they can't tell you what they ne there
yeah well
I guess here's this stunted and and I it
was so weird for me because I was
switching vets and I it was so hard for
me to do because I was well there's so
many documents like how her and they
just like yeah we got him yeah they
emailed more the same thing like it was
just such a weird thing to I was just so
afraid of something falling through the
cracks yeah and also I feel like they
redo everything they don't trust the
other vet I nope I don't know if they
did any of this right I got to read you
the ultrasound I got to read you this so
true yeah it was so fun except I just
came from this place oh god let's just
do this over yeah watch vets like it
like it like who's like throw shade at
each other it was very validating I love
you and your dog oh this is actually
another reason that I felt like I was
like yes she's worth being friends with
making time for I didn't know I was a
friend interview oh yeah oh no you were
it was touch and go there and I have a
lot of boxes you have to check yeah I
said sure you know it's I think that
it's hard you know like I I didn't have
you know a lot of sisters growing up and
I wanted so badly to have a lot of
girlfriends but sometimes you just let
people in too soon without vetting I
haven't we were in the powers you know
you're like I came in you're like she's
the word her and her fucking carpet with
her and and I have made the mistake of
getting too close to people before I
really knew their character and and I
think it's hard to make new old friends
yeah as you get older you know and we
have less time and and but one thing
that sort of like pushed you to the
front of the line is you're a dog person
and a horse person oh yeah and dog and
horse people are you horse people
especially I always say that if you can
it doesn't have to cost you money you
have to own a horse you don't have to at
least a horse some kind of like
volunteer situation with horses is so
good for especially young women because
it teaches you about being a good leader
yeah your presence you have to be
decisive you
to be in charge of your body you have to
have strong boundaries you have to be
very clear and you have to protect
yourself because these can be dangerous
animals they also take your lead so you
need to feel secure so they feel secure
that's because if you're scared they
don't realize you're scared of them they
think oh my God we're in danger that's
right so you need to make them feel safe
that's right so you're at a very young
age you're caring about the energy
you're putting off that's right because
they're prey animals and then any kind
of self-doubt insecurity needing their
approval needing something from them
they they only know fear and not fear
yep they don't know I'm worried I won't
get this photo for my Instagram they
don't know yeah and I also feel like
dogs they want to please you more horses
they're like I don't want her energy get
away from me that's right they don't
need it because there they greatest they
don't need dogs need food from you right
so they need something from you whereas
horses they have grass like they their
reward is your tranquility it's not a
treat no that's why you don't hear a lot
of people being like that's a bad horse
they had a bad owner nope the horse is
just they have their own personality and
they've separated maybe and pulled back
for moments because they had a bad owner
yeah but they're not changing their
personalities Betty so true and they're
very forgiving and for the most part
very in the moment so if you were a mess
yesterday you kind of get to start fresh
with them today we haven't sort of cool
about horses but um you know I think so
few people understand how much there is
to learn from horses about your ego
about your presence you know I think
horses really teach you how to be regal
and you're essentially auditioning to be
the lead mare yeah
the horse that they trust and look to to
make good decisions but ultimately
you're asking
you can't overpower a horse and ever one
you'll never win so you're asking for
them to trust you yes you have to meet
halfway and yeah I think that it teaches
you how to deal with people it really
helps with where you're coming from
knowing where you're coming from and it
teaches you how to earn respect yes you
know and I think that a lot of people
demand respect feel entitled to respect
and horses are a great way to practice
just earning it and learning trust over
time because you can't force someone to
respect you
and that is kind of one of the biggest
lessons I've learned in life you can't
force someone or convince someone to
respect you your behavior just has to
it's also hard work mucking stalls and
that's right add a brush taking care of
another living being it's hard work
you're dirty you're in there and I just
I think looking care yeah I think it's
important like no one wants to hang out
with someone who's like ill yeah totally
and yeah and it's it's I know we've very
strong immune system I never got sick as
a kid because I was always like I
probably wasn't disgusting like I would
muck stalls barefoot no boundary I love
that not at all just the hookworm imine
MLV but so I was kind of like okay this
is like a horse person like I know I can
trust this person I know this person is
you also have to be loyal like there's
just so many things that come along with
whether you're volunteering whether you
have a horse whether you you know do a
clinic or whatever it is I just didn't
even just watching horse videos like I
just you know I just really encourage
that for anybody that can it's it just
really builds a certain type of person
and appreciations there's such powerful
amazing animals being in front of them
you feel how powerful and amazing they
are and they're allowing us that's right
to get on their back which is their most
vulnerable place of the body yeah I
think that's so powerful to get that
approval and then earn that respect for
them and I also think that it really
working with horses
has taught me a lot about what I can and
can't control and when to surrender and
when not to which has served me in so
many ways that professional situations
where it's like is it worth having a
conversation with this person or do I
just walk away yeah or is this a
situation I can change or do I just shut
my mouth and sit on the bench like the
only way to win is to not play and
horses teach you you develop that muscle
of like you know I just walk away and
let this play out or I just get off
because I can't control this like it
just helps you with making really good
decisions very quickly because you don't
have a lot of time now you don't have
time with horses yeah and I think it
also teaches to be super present because
you can get hurt at any moment and I
find myself the more I'm a fight phone
the more I'm like a walking zombie
how can a wall I literally will like
walking walls at this point I'm like not
paying attention i misspelled words like
anything just being on my phone all the
time it just made me sloppier and that
when i'm with a horse I'm just I feel so
alert and you have to be you know it's
just like good to get that muscle back
yeah
and you cannot be on your phone you can
not be on your phone you be stepped on
it will be an accident but bad I've
gotten injured so many time I mean I
have you have to and I think kids see
I'm very Pro injury great you know you
sort of make better decisions you know
like I got too comfortable with a horse
one time I still have a dent in the side
of my leg and it just was like yeah I
was being sloppy yeah I agree I mean I
trusted my horse too much yeah and one
time you know it was cold and he was
feeling how I kicked me yeah I mean I
deserved it well hurt and it also helped
me a lot of relationships because horses
are very good at knowing like we can be
close but we don't need to be entrenched
like the healthiest relationship so
they're like oh yeah I would like do my
homework in his stall me too and I would
go in my horse sister and I would like
sleep with you know that's how I am but
he sort of reminds me like at any moment
if I hear a you know bamboo or a tree or
I you know cuz their prey animals they
can hear things that are a mile away we
can't hear they also have their
different personalities yes
like I it just horses aren't the same
they're just like dogs in that sense
like sometimes you might get around a
mean horse and some drives so you have
to learn their personalities and how to
be around them respect them yeah the
same with people I think that you go
into relation with the people people
will see phones I've totally ruined my
brain where you go into a situation and
you just as our relationship yeah look
well this worked in the last
relationship factly and it's gonna work
here is it start new start new horses
teach you like you have to like start
from scratch and really get to know
someone for you sort of engage with them
so they don't kick you in the thigh yep
I want to talk about strong for me
timpani okay so I we worked for the same
trainer as you can tell she works with
them away more than and I am on the road
so much and I think a lot of people can
relate to like I want to work out I
don't have a home gym I don't have a
trainer right and I have
thirty minutes when I land in this hotel
before I have to go to this work thing
like how can I best use that thirty
minutes that's actually why I created
strong for me because Ben Bruno our
shared trainer and friend he used to
write me workouts while I was on the
road continue living a healthy lifestyle
and ultimately we talked and I wanted to
give this to women that have to have
access because you're right you know I
do have a personal trainer I do have you
know a nutritionist telling me what to
eat so now I'm providing that to every
woman and now you know I partnered with
urban remedy so you can get the food
that I that's what we have that's what
we need really the urban remedy
smoothies yeah that's what we so that's
pretty strong for me and oh my god yeah
and they you owe me like four hundred
dollars right no no yeah so it's
delivered straight to your door and it
helps you continue living that healthy
lifestyle and I think thirty minutes a
day is so that you do in your house is
so attainable well having hearing people
and like for me to be like oh no like
you can get this body just work out
three hours a day yeah but I know I see
these things and it's like a two hour
workout I don't need fifty machines
first of all the urban remedies that's
so funny that's what we the berry one
and the blueberry one I love it because
I feel like if I just drink this like
I'm I've checked the boxes for my like
vitamins for the day and I don't have to
now I can County trash today probably
not doing this right but it's just like
a nice I looked at the ingredients I was
like okay if I just do this like I don't
have to stress out fit well and they're
starting the day right so if you do have
but I don't like saying cheat meal but a
meal that you enjoy that maybes not on
your health plan yeah you don't feel as
bad and that's fine I also like we have
to work on not getting into that shame
spiral yes like oh no I had french fries
screw the diet yeah or screw the healthy
like I'm just gonna go off the edge like
we have to just it's fine it's a knife
it's also I was talking to this
nutritionist once who was just like the
stress the the neuro chemicals that
you're gonna emit
stressing out about yeah that thing has
so much worse for you than just eating
the thing so if you're gonna produce a
cortisol and adrenaline over shouldn't
eat this thing or not just eat it and
don't waste it you put your body and
fight-or-flight and so it stores fuchs
it doesn't know when you're gonna eat
again so if you're stressing out about
not eating while you're eating
yeah body starts storing food yeah you
you gain weight that's what we want to
talk about next with strong for me is
start talking about mental health
because like you said stressing out or
going in those same spirals ultimately
you don't get any of the benefits I
don't care if you're eating healthy all
day long we're working out I'm allowed
to say this you probably shouldn't but I
am fine I know a lot of people that are
working out all day and eating well and
they're mentally a fucking mess no we
have to address inside and out yeah a
health okay a lot of times working out
too much and eating certain ways is
actually mentally unhealthy because
you're just you're obsessive yes yes
it's the only thing you think about and
no one wants to be in that position you
want like for me I want health and
wellness to add to my life not being my
life yes I want to have the energy to be
the best mom the best wife still work
yeah I want to like eat to live not live
to eat exactly and I see so many people
in my life like that are doing Crossfit
three times a day and they have all
these injuries and they're only eating
like these paleo flakes or what like
protein powder I'm like this is not
mental yep and that's what I worked on
whenever I was put in that position
starting modeling I only worked out to
fit in a certain dress size or gene size
to be the ideal body that modeling
wanted me to be and now I've changed my
complete mindset yeah ultimately do I
fit in those jeans and dress size yes
but why I'm doing it is to be strong to
be my best self and that puts me in a
much healthier place to add to my life
like we're saying and not for it to be
obsessive and be my life I love that and
that's I mean that's why it's called
trunk for me but yep it's like not about
being skinny
it's about being strong right and the
best version of yourself you know and
and I love I member bended something
these of these two and I want to talk
about them because if you're in your
hotel room and you have a chair right
you have a chair you have a rolled-up
towel some mini shampoo bottles you know
what
can you the average person do and they
would go to your the there's like you
have a bunch of workouts already yeah
it's a 12-week program 30 minutes you
can do yeah hotel at home whatever it is
limited equipment or no equipment yeah
like a would it be called bodyweight
workout it I mean yes but no you can go
into a hotel room yes with some of these
workouts with no weights no it's
creating insistency and you know and
working out smarter instead of harder
what are your favorite three just to do
in your hotel room well I think my
favorites are my least favorite oh
that's such a good way to put it yeah
and it's the that sucked them all
exactly the split squats you know so you
put like the elevated foot Scott's one
of your foot on the chair and and dip
down and fold up a little towel so that
you don't get rug burn on your knee
right get rug burn in other ways
yeah sure favorite for that yeah sure
like that's a good one you know if I
like to do I like to do lunges down the
hallway I'm that person yep I'm that
dickhead and then I'm also the person
that stretches on a plane everyone's
like oh yeah that's like a sleep well
you're stretching that's a good is there
stuff you can do in your while you're on
the plane
I mean who would do that on the plane I
know just this like I'm like mental
wellness I used to do i'ma give yourself
a break watch a movie go to sleep oh my
god how long is this flight
that's a wellness I used to bring those
bands with me do you use those yes yeah
love those bands right you can kind of
do them when you're sitting you do the
seated like yeah leg presses like that's
something you can actually pack when you
travel yeah I mean sure do it on the
flight but I'm definitely not going you
know I like doing it nobody talks to you
no one wants to talk to the person
strategy leave headphones on because I
can't even if people continue to try and
talk to me I just can't hear them what's
like an average day like what do you eat
Mackley everyone listening like what
Ajit exactly I have to ask that no I
mean obviously every day it's different
I don't
like it depends on my time I'll either
start off with the smoothie or eggs yeah
I think starting off with breakfast is
so important because then so few people
do that yeah it's just if I don't eat
breakfast I suddenly am starving yeah
and then I'll eat everything in my sight
and I also find that a lot of people
there's two things that I think people
get tripped up on number one if you're
working out more you're gonna be
hungrier right you're gonna have to eat
more and I think people try to diet and
increase their workout simultaneously
and that you can't do that's why that's
why strong for me so great because Ben
took that into consideration and also
like cardio yeah makes you hungrier
that's right and so being smart with
bodyweight workouts is not going to
increase it is gonna increase your heart
rate so that you're burning calories
throughout the day but it's not going to
be burning calories so much in just 30
minutes
yeah where you walk out and you're like
I will eat the entire cow yeah now
vegans are gonna attack me they'll come
for me to worry I uh Ben is so funny
because Ben is so I remember the first
time was the first time like like Ben's
so smart and he also then the reason
that I recommend him so much and the
reason I think people should go to
Kate's on this is he he also specializes
in really intense exercise that's not
gonna injure you yes so I think a lot of
people don't understand like I see
people the gym doing these crazy things
and doing 30 40 reps and when I first
start working out with Ben we would do
these like 20-pound 20-pound weights I'd
have in each hand and I'd be doing these
squat lunges is that what they're called
yeah I don't know I don't even know what
squats okay and I would do he'd be like
okay two eight and I'd be like well I
can do ten like I'm so strong and he's
like no do eight and I'm like but I can
keep going he's like there's a reason
I'm picking this number yeah and it's so
you don't get injured well and yeah and
so that you're being smart and aren't so
sore the next day where you don't work
out you can't work out if you're
creating consistency in your life or
you're injuring yourself yeah and he was
basically saying after eight
you're gonna start using your back
exactly I don't want you using your back
I want you using your glutes and I just
was like well but like I
we all think we're so good he's like
there's a science behind this right
there's a reason that the experts make
the rules and sometimes when I get in
the gym I like to make up my own rules
right based on how I'm feeling and it's
arrogant it's just like sloppy and
arrogant and I when I work out on my own
I'm like you know I'm just gonna do 20
and like you know I just had one of my
caffeine drinks and then the next day
I'll have my back on her exactly I was
working out with a friend of mine she
just started working out and I was like
I'm gonna do 12 you should probably
start at 8 and she was like nope and did
12 on everything and I'm not a personal
trainer so yeah I'm not gonna like fight
with her yeah I like hinted I was like
maybe don't want to be sort yeah the
next day so sore yeah couldn't move back
was killing her and then she didn't work
out when she walked out again and I was
it was funny because I wouldn't bet and
I we'd work out together I would get so
bored like I'm so like oh I get so bored
sometimes I'm working out but we would
take breaks and I'd be like let's just
go let's just knock this out he's like
no your muscles need to recover I need
you to do this protein drink and have
some water and your heart rate needs to
go up and down that's right yeah so it
was it was so just funny that I thought
I knew what I was doing and then when I
first went in with Ben I was like well I
don't want to build muscle because
that's gonna make me bigger that's gonna
put on weight like that kills Ben Hey he
literally like walked away from like
collective self he's always like
everyone's like I want to look like all
of your clients but I do not want to
lift weights he's like that's what I do
people don't understand Leah people are
think that lifting weights like makes
you fat and also like trust me you don't
have the bill to ever look like the
bodybuilder guy don't worry
yeah I know people like I don't want to
look like a bodybuilder don't worry like
let's say you do two push-ups yeah and
then we'll talk about that is that why
you're not so I think I had that
misconception when I went in lifting
weights does not make you bigger I think
I had this misconception that running
was cart the only kind of cardio where
you lose weight and that lifting weights
just made you big not true not true at
all and again Ben is so smart
is his weightlifting is specifically to
not gain weight lean and that's the
other reason that you only do a certain
number of reps so you don't get bulky
you get lean exactly and like focus on
different areas and I think there's so
much information especially with social
media there's so many trainers out there
that aren't you get air quotes I'm like
oh yeah we're on a podcast yeah that uh
they're not legitimate people maybe they
lost weight they know how to work out
for their own body type but now we're
taking their advice yeah and they don't
know how to properly yeah you know lift
weights for everyone
for every woman's body yeah and Ben is
qualified you know he went to Columbia
like he's super smart this is like what
he does is this what he does and I had a
broken shoulder and he's really good at
helping you work out if you've had
injuries and all of these are really
safe but it's it's a I think people just
think they can go to the gym and watch
people on Instagram and just like do it
like sometimes it's the difference of an
inch right and it's a difference between
building muscle and injuring yourself
exactly and that's why strong for me
isn't you know it's its own brand and I
wanted to pull experts together to give
reliable information to women on health
and wellness your science it's not my
blog what funny
this is experts coming together and
telling you what works real science yeah
true facts as we call them true real
fact exactly and and then okay so
everyone's gonna do that I also just
have to ask you what you do to your skin
our people are gonna lose their minds
what I do for my skin and what do you
put on it oh I mean finally I'm just
silent no yeah I am I don't know I
always it with yeah I love Luzerne oh
good yeah that's a really good read yeah
use zer any not exactly on milk and then
I love Tammy fender uh-huh
great different hydration moisturizer
yeah
drink water love a sheet mask Oh a sheet
mask
a particular one that you lamb I love
Joanna Vargas oh yeah she's really good
yeah I was so hungover after I had my
baby after the ash was won in the World
Series and we and my husband and I were
heading to our wedding like obviously
was a big miss half of it yeah and God I
didn't go I wouldn't even seen you so I
was on the plane and like Jessa did I
look terrible we both put on Joanna
Vargas's sheet mask and our skin was
glowing now I'm just like they work they
work see where does he keep his trophy I
I don't think there is a trophy there's
a ring they're all got him wear a mic
otherwise I think I sold it on eBay but
where does he keep his ring does he wear
it um he doesn't really wear it like
where would you wear it I don't know
it's trick they give all these guys
jewelry that they came and wear yeah I
think it's I don't know he wears it to
some I think he's worn it a couple times
huh
are you still playing tennis yeah oh
please we took a couple tennis lessons
together yep I I just I don't like
tennis for some reason why cuz I'm bad
at it you know why I don't like being
bad at things this is my problem is I
don't like being bad at things in order
to get good things you have to be bad at
them for a while and I was so
inconsistent yeah tennis is so easy too
because it's such a reflection of your
focus and you can have a bad day right
and I just get frustrated because I'm
full McEnroe I'm like throwing brackets
like I get so angry I always find that
to be my excuse though like oh I haven't
played in so long that's why I'm bad at
yeah I lean in look at you but I I'm
Ana's big kick where I just love to
learn new things as it keeps things
interesting especially with exercise
exactly you have to keep things exciting
and challenge yourself and I just was
like you know what I was too much this
was like three years ago or something I
was too much at the time
I'm a perfectionist about how much of a
workout something was and you've gotta
let it go you gotta let it go and I
couldn't do it's all about not thinking
it's a workout that's why I love to
learn because I'm focused on learning
this that I don't even realize I'm doing
so I'm doing so much cardio this is why
I didn't I'd never did yoga and I just
kind of started doing it again because I
was like this isn't I'm not getting
enough of a workout I drove all the way
down here I would have like expectations
for how hard something would be yeah so
that I could check the boxes like I
worked out and tennis like I would go to
the lesson and I go today we're only
hitting I'm like but I but I need like a
workout and he's like this isn't a
workout you're learning a skill and I
couldn't like once you get good we can
start playing and that'll be a workout
but you have to get good first no see I
tell people that I just want to do
cardio tennis but I do have the basics
hmm oh yeah no you're very good at it
and I'm not very good but I yeah I can
hit the ball yeah I'm definitely better
than you but yeah so I'll tell them I
want cardio tennis like throw me a few
pointers yeah but keep me moving yeah
and they're V and they're very used to
that
yes I'm like I'm not going to be Serena
Williams yeah like I'm out here to have
good time letting out was so now with
these awesome people like you I I just
I'm so competitive like I played
basketball very competitively and I just
it's really hard for me to just be like
kind of okay at something yeah and I get
I get frustrated and I think that's
something that that working out with Ben
helped me because it just was like he's
he would say he's like there's no reason
you should be good at this yet yeah you
know and I think that just like always
trying to impress people yeah what am i
doing like why would anyone he'd be like
why would I expect you I was like WOD
why don't I lift this and he's like what
is this what are you trying to impress
me I know what you're capable of you
can't trick me like you're paying me for
this time I'm already you know I think
just like I you know I don't know I just
like get in my head and I really just
want to be the best at everything and
what does that serve you yeah you know
yeah you're just like super annoying you
just everyone else you would someone's
going person no one likes that person
I I don't know if you're like trying to
compete with the best though yeah then
they're like listen I will always beat
you what else are we talking about we're
talking about strong for me
so website Instagram yep strong for me
urban remedy anything else what else
what else our friendship or plugging our
friendship we're plugging strong for me
oh and I want you to show oh you know
what I wanted to ask you about oh yeah
oh this this is do you ever use these
oh yeah the app wheel I love it I come
on and you're like she's a fitness
expert dude this is my favorite I bring
this on the road with me and you do it
on the plane I'm still in bed I'm never
going anywhere with you Southwest the
only time that my behavior would be the
least terrible no I look I wanted to ask
you if it was bad for you no I um Ben
has them we do them they're definitely
not bad for you I think the I think the
only thing is if you don't do it right
and you extend too much you can hurt
your back that's correct which is what I
do but this thing you can pack I've
packed this on trips before and I do at
my hotel room because it's your abs and
your chest and your arms yeah I really
like it it's smart that you pack that
yeah I mean I don't know what kind of
suitcase you bring away luggage their
response are always away yeah you just
put it in with all your stuff
the people at TSA look at me kind of
weird oh there's like dog shit on will
you check like you operate carry-on
sometimes they're like where are you go
make Expo I love this Avenue and I feel
like people think working out has to be
so complicated like like push-ups dude
yeah people think that you have all put
in an hour or you're not getting any
benefit yeah it's not true just just get
in something yeah and this is um like a
very 80s invention so I think people
sleep on it but I think this is a good
tool I literally have cobwebs on it
pretending like I - we have like like an
AB wheel workout on shark vermin I'm not
kidding this is a very good thing that
anyone can put in their house
it is good and it's good I will smoke
first - no can we get me a tie in can
you call ad sales be base in you what a
fun great app we all is you're like no I
only needed my one rumba I feel like we
are just like nailing life right now
okay we have to get you out of here
because you have to go to the west side
is there anything else you want to plug
motherhood just motherhood in general
mother it's great mental health go too
strong for me if we have time we might
shoot a little videos and you show us
stuff love youth is this your first
podcast you got no wow sorry like
believable no but is my favorite you're
out there doing podcast without time is
not really rude I thought we were
friends
I'm like don't you follow me no way
I don't know well get in that I love you
thank you thank you so much often we got
Kate Upton's it's great this is so fun
come on you're the best
Oh easy Oh I end them very awkwardly
[Music]